well outside outside again it's good
yeah i'm outside this time hopefully you
can hear me okay I haven't met a star
but it was kind of crowded inside so I
thought it'd be better in here out here
okay cool cool yeah i think last time
was that side too mmm good okay so for
those of you watching uh this is the
fourth video with Jen we're here to help
her build her movement around her one
word which is fantasy and it's been a
month since we last connected what's up
Jen what has been going on well just
making progress on my book my YouTube
and Twitter probably the two biggest
places I've grown um i posted three
videos since we talked last oh look a
long one yeah I saw one of them was like
more professionally produced part of the
series of the sales page copy and then I
did the one the day that you and I
talked you challenged me to do it in the
next 10 minutes so I did that yeah okay
okay and then the red wine which was
sorta you know it was just a fun one to
kind of practice and keep me going on
there so yeah okay cool yeah yeah so uh
yeah I'm excited cuz I brainstorm some
more ideas for posting fantasy videos
about copyrighting continuing my sales
page copywriting series and then also
have the idea of doing one kind of a
round around they mean a different
elements of coffee kind of similar to
how you've named your worksheets to be
zucca um yeah something like that so I'm
think I'm gonna do something like that
with famously copyright so I'm excited
about that ok cool yeah well this time
we hope the main thing I wrote down was
having the getting consistent with the
schedule right right good you know I'm
doing okay i have it on my calendar
that's good it's like all my calendar to
do every sunday which is a great day for
me to do it um a few things have
happened since we taught you know i went
on vacation and i also got a major car
accident so it sort of introduced
something down a little bit but I still
I still stay to my schedule I still
worked on either a video or copy
or I'm sorry our blog post onset every
sunday that i had so i have been bad
though I have to admit about posting
another blog post i have one like ninety
percent written i was so like i wanted
to post before we talk but i didn't I
have to admit I didn't finish it but I'm
looking to post it today by the end of
the day sorry how are you feeling after
the accident I'm feeling much better
thank you yeah yeah yeah I'm uh yeah
it's been in a way it's been um Greg
because I've had a little bit more time
to write I kind of was stuck to my my
bed or couch for a week but I'm feeling
much better thank you I broke I broke
four ribs and it's miracle time around
walking but yeah I can't like move too
much and what you on this side I've they
all are on one side so and i can't i'm a
dancer and a runner and i can't do that
for a couple more weeks probably but I'm
gonna we'll see i have positive
fantasies about doing about getting back
in the swing of it i like it you know
and this is an opportunity to unity it
more comfortable with the video that
could be that could be a good video like
i am here at home i just got into a car
accident I cannot move you know and I'm
still having a positive attitude about
it and tying in fantasy to say hey now
it gives me more time to write and
looking on the bright side and it's not
about the copywriting but it ties into
what you're doing and it makes it
personal so the next time i watch your
video I remember you a little bit more
yeah okay that's a good idea I did my
blog post that I have I almost ready is
about my accident okay so um but I like
the idea of doing that video too that's
a good idea bow both can work that's
great the videos are great when they're
in the moment so I decided to experiment
with because you kind of did won the
last two have been fun so you did the
one I challenge you on the spot and you
I think it was still advice related
right right our impromptu and then the
birthday one was more fun hey Here I am
in was in Mexico yeah I was the next
killer birthday right
um and so having a mix is good between
the professional advice the polished
videos and then either an opinion or
something personal happening no opinion
ideally you're in the moment like you
know somebody somebody cuts you off on
the way home and you're upset about it
and you have a you know strong opinion
about it like that's the time when you
go home pick up your phone rah doesn't
have to be professionally waiting for
the camera to set up and you know you
daughter to help you or whatever right
just make it on the positive side to
like something great happening you're
really feeling that moment then in that
time right away you start filming
because your emotion will come out more
on camera than if you're doing it like
the next Sunday ah you try to remember
back to how you felt and it doesn't come
across as well right yes I totally agree
that's true sorry go ahead yeah if he
does don't have to be I know you like to
think it out and plan it and you know
prepare notes and everything it's great
but sometimes what that does is makes it
such a big task that you don't do it
right which is the last time right the
challenge last month was ok you have ten
minutes make a video you can do
something but still really good right
now off the cuff right so you don't have
the time then you could still make
something impromptu without of being
perfect like you don't need three hours
to make this you can do it in ten
minutes right now I thought that was a
great challenge that you presented to me
because it did sort of like open my eyes
to its really Jen you can make a video
in 10 minutes like you don't have to you
know you don't have to like overthink it
and and then when you said the same
thing my birthday I was like okay I'll
do it again because I agreed i'd totally
was like okay god did it and it was so
funny because it was like literally just
before the rain storm came in i don't
know if you saw that video it was just
kind of funny i'm like okay i really
gotta hurry cuz i see in the rain storm
coming um but anyway it was just really
good and so when I did my next video on
the sales page I did one on headlines I
don't know if you saw that one oh yeah
yeah so when I did that one I didn't
prepare as many notes like my other ones
I like memorize everything word for word
and I just feel like because I didn't
memorize everything I kind of went off
the cuff a little bit i mean obviously
was prepared but not not like i had been
before like every single word and um I
just feel like more of my personality
came through because it was more me just
talking from the heart rather than you
know this memorized grip that I came up
with so right yeah Jason is running in
we want more spontaneous videos all in
capitis awesome all right more
spontaneous let's get the mixed up
obviously you know that the professional
ones the advice ones are the ones that
will help you generate more business but
the person ones make it personal so I
get connected to you more and the more I
watch it the more mimic feel connected
you and I'm gonna want to buy your your
server right right absolutely okay I've
been liking the twitter stuff you put up
okay you know I check in every day and
see what new suck you put enough but if
it's a hope that somebody wrote or you
know an opinion you have some of those
it's been pretty good um I would since
this is your area biggest growth right
you know if we look at our numbers to
four months a month what I would suggest
is with each begin that you put up make
sure that it is something that you're
really really next to you right that
you're really proud of not just for a
post but something that like yeah I'm
really I'm really happy with that
sometimes it's a retweet that you put
out from somebody else that's okay but
you should really feel really deeply
proud of every tweet that that comes up
right and they are pretty good like
already there solid you you know I have
to reread a couple of them sometimes
just to absorb it which is which is okay
um right right that's good I like that I
like they're good they're fun um that
would be my only challenge to you some
of them some of them I don't get and
that's okay um as long as each one that
you have
you feel strongly connected to if you
feel the world needs to know this
information right um are you still doing
I used to recognizing people the frantic
leader of the day yes I am although
captain I didn't do it last week yeah
but I every other week ups to the last
week I've done it so okay the other week
okay yeah okay um so then as you get
more used to the video i agree you don't
want to be memorizing everything and I
did that too it's a comfort zone you
know like you want to make sure
everything is said you want a min um you
know going off the cuff I mean you also
want to think about in advance what
you're going to say maybe not all the
specifics of it but what you're going to
say and what I would suggest is leading
with a strong opinion okay so not you
don't have to lead with the hey I'm Jan
I would frantisek operator and you know
what let me pull up your video where is
it let me pull it up let me go to my now
that you're going practicing this more
and more it's it's good to sure yeah I
love it yes like Ozzie yeah exactly i
know i I noticed that the sneakers like
kind of loud out here which is unusual
for outside but look it's gonna fun why
not that's okay okay can you see my
screen yeah I can't okay so there you
are let's load it up all right let's do
it I'm Jen copywriter egg you so much i
miss fancy my copy my dreams I'm sure
making their pieces together and I would
Jordan Hall its true perspective be
awful so I want to continue my date okay
so have a 20-second intro which in two
full terms are it's really I kind of
paused you on that right right that's
great that's okay doesn't matter look so
20 second intro is long all right
okay so i would rather you come out and
start with whatever opinion you have to
share so if we're talking about
headlines then what is the one sentence
version of this video of what so one
message that I need to understand this
video uh I would say that you need to
get the attention of the people you're
trying to reach you need to reach out
and grab them get their attention right
away so that they don't leave your page
right so great so your headline has to
be so exciting that it reaches out and
grabs people and that raised the stakes
so make it more important what happens
if it's not they're going to leave your
page right so they're going to leave
your page you're not going to make any
sales you've invested all this time and
money into creating this great product
or service and nobody's going to know
about it all because your headline sucks
okay right he now you're making me pay
attention to it normal right okay right
and you can even have your gin the
little white text showed up here and you
so much that's fine you can have that at
the page at the start and you can have
it you can end with what you do and
fantasy copper I mean the idea is people
are going to be watching eagles a series
and you'll be because learning from them
and eventually hire you so you don't
have to go through the whole intro time
oh my that make sense the other thing I
would watch for here is when you are
making a statement and this week this
may be a reflection of you being off the
cuff but when you're making a statement
hoping that you believe in uh-huh in the
in your information to go up right okay
words make it real right okay like a
question and share a definitive
statement gotcha right let's see if I
listen nah I just kind of made that up
that sentence but let's see if it if you
actually said own dancing your reach
it's right because we're taking we all
right yeah I do that you're right
yeah Rhea right I was that the right and
you said it so much that it may not have
as much meaning because he stayed all
the time but you need to each time you
said you gotta make it important because
you're trying to convince me right
you're showing me that words make the
road trying to explain how important
this is and i'll i'll believe it more if
you are passionate about it and you are
definitive about it and not right right
okay yeah um and it'll come with
practice right you've only done like
four videos or something that's it's
yeah gossip he's way ahead of where I
was so I would just watch that across
all of all of what you're saying when
you're trying to get a point across your
kind of make it definitive to the Lord
is partly feeling definitive right
definitive you'll have to watch it oh
did I go up then I take a walk on that
if you are feeling definitive about it
and yes you need to know this and yes
this will save your business you will
not go yes this will save your business
right you will you and your action about
it then your students will be definitive
and they won't go up so that's that yes
okay I totally makes sense right yeah
okay let's watch a little bit more okay
my video series of how do you see you
here could you hear it over the music
there yeah yeah okay um so because this
is now we're so for eliminating the
first 20 seconds this is the next what
13 seconds this is what we're strong
opinion to be oh you don't we don't need
with continuing our series about sales
copy pages because you've got an
important headline because people want
to buy from you it's different it's
telling what you do which is great it's
just not a new know this from your
coffee it's not hitting me
right yes you wouldn't lead a sales
letter saying though I'm continuing my
series about it you're right I wouldn't
that's ready okay right so yeah and at
the same time I don't want you to be so
scripted that you're memorizing
something and you're not excited and
feeling it right so this is the balance
and this is why you need to practice you
know keep going out keep making these
videos because each time you do it
you'll get better okay right but Watson
so absent of you the answer they always
include on a website so face Adams your
headline customer focus message I love
that unless I acted ology you call it
something what do you have here just
like elements for a website sales page
copy elements from inside sales page so
good you'll be the copywriter right that
headline could be more right yeah that's
what I was talking about the beginning
like maybe rename all those and just
something much more exciting yeah even
the first one like that headline copy
elements website sales page could be a
lot more interesting a lot more fantasy
yeah more and even if you keep the rest
the same yeah hold lying around last
time you talked about flow i think on
there right yep i dad yeah we talked
about small okay we haven't done okay
yeah perfect um I look different i mean
it's a minor thing the audio is a little
bit different than a video of your video
right holdin it for my different video
right right yeah okay yeah you know if
you're gonna do this ongoing may be
worth reporting this part again with
your new with whatever microphone you're
using now for your videos report and
with a little more energy okay it's like
if you're going to be using this slide
and talking about all those you know how
many
point seven points or whatever it is
mm-hmm having a video then this becomes
super important so like if you listen to
your voice in how you present this so
it's okay just kind of reading it right
yeah yeah so that one's worth in
festival but more time and to really
mean it and then reporting the audio
again and maybe even rebranding that
page a little bit to have your your your
logo and information I don't like you
there Rodia yeah Jason wrightson make up
a name he wants a name okay the people
want a name yeah your pink you have to
paint colors here but the way you've
done your facebook pictures with the
your font and their logo on there this
is something you want people ideally
this could be something even
downloadable right the people will then
care and refer to and you are the expert
you've created this methodology and
super important so the page feel that
important okay I'm like the action 60
I'm going to talk about headlines and
how mines are obviously super important
because it's the first thing your
customer is going to leave when they
land on your page and so that definitely
needs to reach out and grab them it
needs to tell them that they are in the
right place that they are understood and
it really speaks to their desires some
of the things we want and the other
thing about her lines is if there's sort
of a pose in there there's a promise
that it's gonna give them something
that's gonna solve the problem of theirs
and make up things become true um and
then of course the other thing about
headlines is obviously you really want
them to continue being down the page so
that it happen has to be compelling
enough to get them victim reading so
your main goal for headline is just to
get them to rig the very next line
straight so that was good hey you know
it could be condensed a little bit more
okay when I would add to it is
who raised the stakes hunt so make it
more important okay like what is if you
have a bad headline right people leave
your page and you don't want to leave
your page yeah right and efforts and
pizza empathize with them where it's not
just people leaving your page it's you
know you spent all this time creating
this amazing product and service that
you trying to benefit the world and
people are ignoring you because you have
bad copy on your website okay right so
it's not just yet make it bigger it's
not just people will leave your page
like okay well so what you tie it into a
bigger thing well that means no sales
and that means you know you're not
achieving your goals as a business owner
you don't have any impact so you're
making it more important because the
more important it is the more likely
going to take action and want to pay
attention to it yes I might you want to
make it important yeah absolutely okay
let's get going headlines to you today
by showing you some coffee that I wrote
for a website sales pitch for HOSA
volcom Ojin and oh so bold is this
really neat website launched a little
bit hard to read their over your face
just a minor thing okay you use that
same like font from the beginning where
your name is on the right are on the
left right a little bit easier to read
okay it's a community building site for
women who are looking to increase the
courage of life they're really looking
for more fun and more passion and they
really want to connect with other women
who can support them and give them
advice and you're basically just like
minded women were looking at making bull
change my wife and so the first step
that I always do when I'm writing copy
is really you think about the target
customer think about how are you need to
know them so well all the way down to
what they eat for breakfast what they
like to do on their free time and so
with oh so bold they're really a busy
entrepreneur mom who doesn't make time
for themselves who loves to read it
loves to travel really wants more
freedom in their life wants to have more
fun wants to dance what's good museum
and
to cook so those are the things that are
really important to just really can't
wait little details like that you're
talking to somebody on your website the
sick so okay so it's good and I love
that you know you have the point showing
up there on the page um tru thoughts
here the first you can you have room for
personal aside uh-huh the the the mexico
trip video is is great like it's all
personal and then this is all
professional but you could there's room
for a five-second personal touch here we
can say it's a website for moms who want
to be we want to take bold action in
their lives and you know they may be
busy moms and entrepreneurs inks and
this is something i could totally relate
to being a mom entrepreneur myself so
work with them right like five seconds
but you make it a little more personal
you add just a little bit extra touch to
it hopefully get you uh getting you a
little more amped up for the video as
well and more into it right well and i
love that idea because that'd be like
you said it would have taken like not
even five seconds to say that and then
anyone help there was it not to premier
mom it's like oh cool she's like me yes
exactly then the girly yeah we're free
we have a comment from iron grader who
wrote in to say keep all the links you
talked about in the description of your
videos keep all the way all the links so
you're talking about oh so bold you
could put that in the description he
wants us to other link great idea okay
thank you i am greater that's awesome
yeah okay so let's see so it's all okay
then my second thought there was it's a
deep you have I just add a little more
clarity to this so people can follow
along a little more easily so the point
was what was the point no your customers
right exactly and in small detail yeah
well new customers are so you start of
with one point like it's important to
know your customers and write that in
the headline because right why you
target the wrong audience you're not
going to get results whatever it is i
think i'm going to model it so for
example
you know the oh so bold typical client
is this kind of person okay say why all
right that makes sense because I kind of
say it later but it might we might get
lost in translation it jumps right make
sense in your mind and it's how you work
which is great watching along and kind
of jumps and we're having to tie the
pieces together a little bit so if you
make it easier for people to follow
along then they'll follow a lot right
that much better I got it okay what do
they want it step is to figure out what
they really want what their desires are
and what it is that you're offering it's
going to help make their fantasy a
reality and so in the case of oh so cool
calm but they're really looking for is
more time for themselves more time to
have some more fun and more time to make
bold changes in their lives so that
could be a personal aside right more
time to have buy more time for their
family more time right like you don't to
do a personal side every single point
but if you have one or two in a video
then you just throw it in there yeah
okay as a little human touch to it and
were to help them do that and then the
third step is to figure out how they
want to feel this is super important
what is it that your customer really
wants to feel and in a case of oso
volcom she really wants to feel good
about the changes that she's making in
her life she wants to feel guilt free
about spending time on herself about
making huge changes in her life and get
support how the friend who's there for
her as she's doing that maybe someone
who understands he's been there and can
help her give her advice along the way
so I put those three things together and
came up with this headline are you ready
to bring your bold well then girl turn
up got 90s R&B and let's hip hop to it
right so there's a few things but it's
how long that I wanted to talk about
because every word is very carefully
chosen so the first part are you ready
to bring your bolt right away you're
talking to somebody who's ready to bring
some fold changes into their life and
then we're also addressing the girls so
if the girl answer that page they are
like feel
gum that they're in the right place
where's a guy is gonna know they're not
right the last part there turn up that
90's R&B and let's hip hop to it if you
remember our customer loves to dance she
loves nineties rmb she loves hip-hop and
she really wants to bring more fun into
her life so that does all of that right
there another reason why it's super
important to know details about your
customers and then the final thing i
want to point out is it worth less the
word let's is the promise it's the
promise that says hey you're not going
to do this alone I'm going to help you
and show you how and give you support
and friendship that you need ok so again
so it's taking a lot that's a great
point evens things about the let's it's
taking all the stuff that you know and
and you breathe in your copy and bring
it in your videos because it's the same
thing we're communicating to people we
want them to take an action so if the if
the lats was it so blacks is out does
that what was super important that makes
me feel like you understand me right
yeah so that could be what you use when
you're explaining the concept so if
you're saying number three point is know
your customers or no other desires it's
really good explain it right you have to
know desires why it's important explain
the why and then so let's look at right
you can use your so let's yeah
explanation afterwards right if that's
important in your philosophy of
copywriting bring those elements into
your video as well that totally makes
sense repeated the steps you want to go
through when you're crafting a headline
is number one know who your target
customer is down who's much detail as
possible number two what are their
fantasies what are their desires and how
are you going to make them a reality and
number three is how do they want to feel
how are you going to convey that with
that headline and then you want to tie
all those three together and really make
a promise and make it really compelling
and really get that customer to read the
next one okay and as you're doing this
really take some time to think about
your customers fantasies
they struggling which is a really deeply
desire and who's able to become and how
can you do that and I hope you continue
to think about how to make your
customers fantasy a reality if you want
to know more about me and my fantasy
copywriting you can find me online at
you so much calm and don't forget to
write down your own fantasies because
words make it real I did that again well
you know it was better that one had more
let me flip back through camera here
that one had more passion behind it
that's what I that's what I want when
you're saying something like fantasy or
when you're saying words make it real
you want to have energy behind it so the
video that's okay it was better than
what you did it to start I like you know
you had your call to action the only
thing I might add is for people watching
if they have questions they leave it in
the comments below okay that's a great
idea yeah that we type obviously I do
that every day I get you get used to it
I didn't the start yeah but if you had
that at the at the end and it would
encourage people to ask you questions
and then that would give you ideas for
what kinds of new videos to write as
well and then when you start those
videos you can say hey I'm answering a
question from right Lisa what I'm
graders right and again he said you
should also have custom thumbnails on
your videos okay you can add some
thumbnails that YouTube automatically
selects three for you you need to be a
partner though I'm pretty sure maybe I'm
greater can can correct me on this but
I'm pretty sure you need to be a youtube
partner upload your own custom
thumbnails but at least look at the
three that they provide for you with
every YouTube video you put up you could
pick from one of three and then make
that your thumb because sometimes the
ones that they pick for you aren't great
right yeah i know this last one I think
I didn't like any of them but I had to
choose one I remember that oh yeah log
into account you can lot you can look at
that thumbnail section and see if
there's an option to upload your own
yeah yeah want to put your face on it
and you can put the words
of what the video is gonna be about I'm
here though you have to be a partner and
that will come like you'll get that
offer as you grow your channel and get
more views more subscribers so so cool
yeah I'm great or dishing out some
advice thank you very much i love it
thank you cool so what's we're a little
bit over but that's okay we are gonna
keep on track you're gonna keep doing
the videos keep doing the blog post
sunday sunday what time morning sunday
afternoon i have his afternoons yeah yep
and if everybody watching they can find
you what you so much um yeah you so much
com I put on YouTube and Twitter yeah on
Twitter it's this as much and on YouTube
I think it's so much video I'd have to
go into my youtube and look at that was
wrong comlink from you so much calm
right yeah if you go on you so much calm
at the bottom of the page there's a link
to my um my video and my I'm sorry my
youtube and my facebook page and my
Twitter awesome yeah leveraging have a
great thank you so much again thank you
i do okay